I'm sure you two will be very happy
together
[Music]
then you are going to have your hands
full when you and mal have a daughter
now has changed your world for the
better
but do you really think you can handle
raising her descendant you're going to
be chasing a baby dragon around the
playgrounds of auradon and what about
her grandmother Maleficent is going to
be the ultimate evil mother-in-law
thoughts and prayers been if descendants
for ever happens it will probably
feature Malin Ben's daughter no doubt
she'll have green eyes and purple hair
but will she surprise us with new powers
here are the powers that Mouse daughter
will definitely have and a few others
she'll surprise us with a understand
Mouse daughter we're going to have to go
all the way back through her lineage we
will need to examine mal and Ben's
parents as well as Milan Ben this little
girl is going to have an interesting
combo of grandparents we can just
imagine the picture your holiday
gatherings king beasts
this little girl is going to inherit a
giant castle she'll be another lucky
lady to hold the title of Disney
Princess but she could be the hairiest
Disney Princess the house of mouse has
ever seen after seeing Ben's
transformation it appears that the whole
beast thing is hereditary now we know
that then turned into a beast because of
Audrey's spell but do you guys remember
the end of descendants two during Emma
and mouths creature fight then let out a
beastly roar so it's likely that Ben's
daughter will inherit those powerful
vocal cords Belle Ben's mom is the
lovely Belle
her love transformed a raging beast into
a handsome King Belle wasn't blessed
with magical powers but she still got
some positive traits to pass down this
future grandmother will most certainly
bestow her love of reading upon her
granddaughter we imagine Belle and her
granddaughter spending hours in her
giant library reading up about countless
adventures in faraway lands but that's
not the only thing that will pass down
to mouths daughter Belle has the ability
to perceive the good and even the most
beastly of characters this gift of
perception will be passed down to Mouse
daughter making her a total force to be
reckoned with Maleficent
speaking of grandmother's you can't get
more wicked or more interesting than the
supreme sorceress Maleficent mouths
daughter is aired to some incredible
powers she will likely have the ability
to shape-shift into a dragon just like
her mother and grandmother both mal and
Maleficent are powerful sorceress mouths
spell casting abilities went from
mediocre and d2 to extraordinary in d3
she became a master at making up spells
in a moment's notice you might want to
think of a spell for her
mouths daughter will have to learn how
to control her powers and since she has
evil roots she'll have to decide for
herself whether she wants to choose good
like her mom or be evil like her
grandmother we hope she makes the
decision Haiti's nothing can beat having
the god of the underworld for a
grandpappy will Hades give his
granddaughter lost souls to rattle
around when she's just a baby walking
around with blue flames coming out of
her head will definitely make a
statement at auradon prep but in
addition to these godlike powers what
else will Mao's daughter inherit from
her granddad we believe she'll also be
blessed with the power of rock Hades is
a master at the electric guitar we're
willing to bet he'll teach his
granddaughter how to shred those strings
we're wondering what effect this combo
of grandparents will have on Mouse kid
watch until the end to find out a
surprising new power that could emerge
then then got a little hairy in
descendants 3 but before then he was a
loving loyal boyfriend and progressive
Prince to the kingdom of auradon then
has pushed the boundaries of his kingdom
turning it into an inclusive
equal-opportunity place where villains
and royalty can come together but he
couldn't have done it without mal we'll
get to her in a second but first what
gifts well been passed down to his
daughter she might have a mighty roar
but she'll also have the power of
fairness then has a gift for being a
compassionate and fair ruler with all of
that villain blood coursing through his
daughter's veins she's going to need her
father's rational tendencies to balance
her out but she'll always be her
mother's daughter mal we've seen mal
cast love spells revenge spells even
food spells but she really stepped into
her power as a sorceress in d3 she
doesn't even meet her spell book anymore
and now that she has teamed up with OMA
she is truly unstoppable additionally
she is the fiercest dragon in all the
land
mouse daughter is going to have some
major magical powers but they might not
manifest in the way we think remember
she will have Ben's genetics as well so
with the combination of been fiercely
DNA Mao's magical skills and Dragon and
God DNA this little girl will be the
most powerful person in auradon and she
could take on the form of an entirely
new creature there's a creature in Greek
mythology called chimera it's a beast
with a lion's head a goat's body and a
dragon's tail wouldn't it be amazing if
mouths daughter could take on the form
of a hybrid creature like chimera she
would be invincible what powers do you
think mal and Ben's daughter will have
and what do you think mal and then we'll
name her sound off in the comments be
sure to subscribe to the thing to be the
first to see our latest videos and click
that thumbs up button while you're at it
thanks for watching catch you next time